2020 you really did us dirty
oh god despite all the hurdles 2020
threw our way
many of our favorite celebrity couples
kept the love alive
and kept us totally swooning i feel your
love every day
ariana grande found herself a man this
year
luxury real estate agent dalton gomez
she confirmed the romance in may when
they appeared in her music video with
justin bieber for stuck with you
[Music]
and this goes without saying but we love
a man who helps his lady make
content it'll be raining all summer but
we'll surely be dancing as it does
then there's gwen stefani and blake
shelton who got engaged in october
after five years of dating somebody that
is let's see humble
kind down to earth selfless
talented on the top of their game
should i keep going i think i'm his
biggest fan i don't want to remember
what i was like before gwen actually if
that answers your question
gwen debuted her massive sparkler on
instagram
and gave fans an even closer look when
she accompanied blake to the 2020
people's choice awards
i'm so full of love from surprise
engagements
to surprise weddings i was asked like is
this your official coming out and i was
like
coming out from where i wasn't anywhere
to come out
of missy nash tied the knot with
musician jessica betts in august
the pair gushed over the romance during
an appearance on good morning america
i knew it was something the moment i met
her but
um when i fell in love is when i desired
no one else
i knew the being in love is new but
loving her as a soul i've done that from
the beginning
raven simone also became a missus it's
been
full of laughs and conversations and
growth
and goal building it feels good to be
able to share a little bit more of my
life to the world
my babes is she's independent she's
self-sufficient and she challenges me
every day she's like you know you ain't
that special i'm like i'm almost it
again
[Laughter]
in june the ravens home star married her
longtime love miranda maday
who unlike us didn't grow up a fan
she's a different mind which is what
attracted me to her i don't think she
went to the disney channel she knew of
me but that's you know she didn't really
she didn't grow up with me we've been
rooting for tiffany haddish to find love
for a minute now because you know how i
be shooting my shot at these men right
and then they shoot me down right the
comedian has always been honest about
what she's looking for
no color lines you know what i'm saying
it doesn't matter what you are where are
you from
long as you're a human being and a man
for right now and i'm not
a responsible grown man well in august
she confirmed she found all that and
more
in rapper common it's about down time
she told stevo's wild ride podcast this
is hands down the best relationship i've
ever been in
and we can't help but bring up the 2020
baby boom
mindy kaling ashley simpson nicki minaj
kevin hart and gigi hadid were just a
few of the many celebs who expanded
their
[Music]
families